accuse sexual predator Nathan chasing
horse won't be going to trial just yet
the Dances with Wolves actor in court
this morning whether the prosecution in
defense they agreed to the delay eight
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy
explains Nathan chasing horse is trying
to get the case against him dismissed he
was unsuccessful in doing that here in
Clark County so now his defense attorney
is going to try to make that argument at
the Nevada Supreme Court what that means
is the case here is on hold for now the
state versus Jason Horse Cedar County
District Court Judge Carly Kearney only
dropping a drug trafficking charge now
chasing horses going to ask the Nevada
Supreme Court to dismiss the remaining
18 counts against him related to the
alleged sexual abuse against two women
earlier this week we brought you an
exclusive sit-down interview with one of
them Karena Leone formerly Corinna
chasing horse she says chasing horse
sexually assaulted her at the age of 14
and abuse continued for years whether he
wants to admit that to himself or not
because
I want him to know that he can't get
away with it anymore
but no one's going to make excuses for
him anymore
and no one's going to try to cover it up
for him anymore chasing horse is
expected back in court here on May 10th
he also faces federal charges the FBI
saying he is seen on video sexually
assaulting an underage girl he also
faces warrants in Montana and Canada
reporting at the Regional Justice Center
in downtown Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8
news now and